zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
passt gute auf euch und auf eure kinder
auf mit diesen worten hat heute der
spiegel getitelt online und sich damit
mit der frage beschäftigt wie gefährlich
corona für kinder ist und vielleicht
auch wie kinder in diesen zeiten
gefährlich für die gesellschaft sein
könnten weil sie sich vielleicht jetzt
in der dritten welle er mit mutationen
anstecken könnten und dann auch ihre
eltern oder ihre familie infizieren
könnten
wir sprechen darüber mit dem präsidenten
der deutschen gesellschaft für kinder
und jugendmedizin ihre und eure fragen
wie immer sehr gerne in die kommentare
oder wenn er die zdf heute app nutzt an
diese e mail adresse und vorab hat uns
schon ein user geschrieben wir reden die
ganze zeit über schüler aber nicht mit
ihnen also wir reden über sie aber nicht
mit den schülerinnen und schülern und
ich finde es schön wenn wir das heute
abend hier machen könnten deshalb an der
stelle auch ganz explizit die bitte
schülerinnen und schüler studentinnen
und studenten jugendliche schreibt uns
wie die situation für euch ist schreibt
uns was ihr für fragen und kommentare
hat und habt und das geben wir dann hier
sehr gerne weiter passt gut auf euch und
eure kinder auf denn die regierung die
macht das nicht das war nicht nur der
spiegel titel heute sondern das war auch
ein tweet einer sehr wütenden virologin
in dieser woche und wir haben mit ihr
gesprochen
dabei gehe ich eben genau nicht um
schulen auch und schulen zu sondern um
schulen sicher wenn infektionsschutz an
schulen ist auch kinderschutz
da sollte man keine anderen maßnahmen
ansetzen als bei erwachsenen und die
durchleuchtung der kinder nicht einfach
als kollateralschaden da haben die
betreiber der pandemie das ist für mich
quasi das für mich das unwort des jahres
und sie müssen natürlich sehe die
kontakte zwischen eltern und kindern
sind ja auch ganz besonderen kontakte
also die wesentlich enger verlaufen und
wenn man das andere atemwegsinfektionen
anguckt dann müssen sie kein biologe
auch diese werden häufig von kindern auf
erwachsene übertragen und leichte
unterschiede gibt
das halte ich für eine akademische
diskussion die uns davon abhält zur
echten lösungen zu dieser thematik zu
kommen also je länger die freude von
schulen und kindern in der fahndung
unterschätzt dass du länger wird dauern
um die schulen gestalten zu können
tja da ist viel drin in dem was doktor
jana schröder sagt biologin und
infektionsepidemiologie am mathias
spital in rheine
welche rolle spielen kinder in dieser
pandemie darüber möchte ich sprechen und
das alles aufdröseln was wir da gerade
gehört haben ich begrüße in köln
professor jörg de ist präsident der
deutschen gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin und leitet die klinik für
kinder und jugendmedizin der uniklinik
köln
herr professor deutsch haben wir versagt
haben wir die schulen nicht zu sicheren
orten gemacht
ich glaube nicht dass man na ja so
schweren pandemie davon sprechen kann
dass du ja versagt habe oder dass irgend
jemand versagt hat ich glaube das ist
auch die falsche frage die frage sollte
immer nach vorne gerichtet sein wie
können wir ab jetzt die dinge besser
gestalten wie können wir die schulen
sicherer machen und da gibt es eine
reihe von möglichkeiten das zu tun
es gibt sehr gute empfehlungen die von
vielen verbänden medizinischer reiz von
den lehrerinnen und lehrern von
elternverbänden vom robert koch institut
gemeinsam herausgegeben wurden
da sind viele sehr gute sehr prägnante
verhaltensregeln und wir haben immer
noch die möglichkeit ein gutes
testsystem für die schulen zu entwickeln
deswegen und ich denke wir sollten nach
vorne schauen herr professor durch wir
sind ja schon lange in dieser pandemie
und das was sie gerade angesprochen
haben die ganzen regeln an die sich die
kinder halten sollen ich glaube das
erleben viele da halten sich kinder
teilweise besser dran als erwachsene
aber das was man tun kann an
rahmenbedingungen an lüftungsanlagen an
an tests da sind wir erleben wir jetzt
gerade dass wir im monat 12 der pandemie
immer noch nicht sagen können wir haben
etwas gelernt und wir haben das zur
verfügung gestellt unter blick ich gar
nicht zurück sondern
blicke ich in die gegenwart und auch in
den nächsten wochen wir erleben
bundesländer die von öffnungs
perspektiven sprechen
sehen sie denn die schulen gut gerüstet
und so sicher gemacht aus dem was man
gelernt hat damit man jetzt sagen kann
in den nächsten wochen sind die kinder
in den schulen nicht gefährdet nein man
kann ganz sicherlich nicht davon
sprechen dass die schule in seinem
jetzigen zeitpunkt völlig sicher sind
das ist alleine daraus abzuleiten dass
die schulen nie für eine pandemie
baulich hergerichtet wurden ganz anders
als die krankenhäuser beispielsweise und
deswegen wird das auch nach wie vor
schwierig sein und ja sie haben völlig
recht wenn man zurückblickt mann würde
sagen man würde sicherlich das eine oder
andere anders gemacht haben aber dennoch
ich plädiere sehr stark dafür dass wir
die verbliebene zeit nutzen um jetzt die
dinge besser zu machen jetzt die
nächsten wochen wir haben jetzt die
osterferien die sollten wir nutzen um
gute testprogramme für die schulen zu
entwickeln und zu sagen als das was uns
bis jetzt nicht gelungen ist aus welchen
gründen auch immer
das sollten wir jetzt angehen und das
macht sie nicht irre dass es diese tests
strategie noch nicht gibt sondern dass
man die osterferien 2021 nutzung eine
test strategie zu entwickeln
sehen sie wir sind natürlich als ärzte
und als als wissenschaftler immer an der
situation dass wir eine das war eine
situation vorfinden müssen und wir
müssen immer handeln können wir müssen
immer in dem moment handeln in dem sich
sozusagen dinge neu kennzeichnen
und wenn wir das jetzt sehen ist es
besser jetzt zu handeln als
zurückzublicken und schuldige zu suchen
ich halte das für völlig verkehrt viele
haben sich geirrt in der pandemie viele
haben sich mehrfach geehrt und das
größte problem war meines erachtens dass
viele sozusagen zu schnell mit
irgendwelchen prognosen mit englischen
punkten nach vorne gestürmt sind die
sich vielleicht dann nicht halten ließen
und dadurch dass auch viel ist ein
problem entstanden ich bin nach wie vor
der meinung wir sind spät dran das ist
keine frage aber die situation ist auch
für kinder und jugendliche nicht so
gefährlich wie für erwachsene
die wir sehen das nach wie vor in den
kinderkliniken wir haben kaum kinder und
jugendliche die bei uns auf den
stationen sind die kinder selbst sind
kaum gefährdet nach wie vor zumindest
nicht durch
die pandemie die kinder sind sehr stark
gefährdet dadurch dass ihnen der
schulunterricht wählt die kinder sind
gefährdet dadurch dass ihnen der kontakt
zu gleichaltrigen fehlt die pandemie ist
nicht das gefährliche sie ist gefährlich
für die älteren
für die erwachsenen zum glück haben wir
jetzt viele ältere geimpft aber wir
haben trotzdem natürlich auch noch noch
viele erwachsene im mittleren alter die
auch betroffen werden können aber in den
für die kinder erleben wir einen
kinderkliniken im moment keine schwere
situation
ich würde das gerne noch ein bisschen
verschieben und gleich darauf gesondert
noch mal eingehen wie sich denn die
zahlen entwickeln würde aber gerne noch
mal ganz kurz bei der situation an den
schulen bleiben und werfe einen blick
hier in die community
da kann man sagen sind die meisten schon
dafür dass die schulen auf bleiben
sollen ich lese mal ein paar vor magnum
eis schreibt über youtube ich denke die
schulen sollten im wechsel modell auf
bleiben da es einfach stoff gibt dem man
sich nicht selbst beibringen kann
aber sollten erstmal genug tests
beschafft werden ehe die schulen wieder
aufmachen noch eine frage zu den tests
der professor deutsch sind sie für eine
testpflicht wie das zum beispiel in
sachsen der fall ist ohne negativen test
kein präsenzunterricht na ja man hat das
ja in sachsen versucht mit der test
pflicht da gibt es natürlich sehr viele
rechtliche bedenken und wir wissen nicht
ob das zu halten sein wird
ich bin eindeutig und wir sind eindeutig
für eine widerspruchsregelung eine
widerspruchsregelung die gibt es
beispielsweise in österreich
das heißt hier kann eine familie
widersprechen wenn sie das nicht möchte
aber andererseits sind diejenigen die
sozusagen vielleicht auch den aufwand
scheuen sich intensiv damit zu
beschäftigen
letztlich diejenigen die dann doch damit
indirekt einwilligen also wir sind
eindeutig für eine widerspruchsregelung
verpflichtende maßnahmen haben immer das
problem dass sie doch rechtlich sehr
stark attackiert werden können
möchte gerne noch eine andere frage
aufnehmen wenn die zuschreibt schulen
sollten jetzt priorisiert geöffnet
worden wenn ein vernünftiges
schutzkonzept besteht das kann ich
allerdings derzeit nicht erkennen daher
kann man öffnungen nicht verantworten
zum schutz konzept gehören auch masken
da gibt es viele eltern die probleme
damit haben dass ihre kinder masken
tragen können sie das vielleicht ganz
kurz noch mal erläutern inwiefern das
für kinder eine rolle spielt ob sie eine
maske tragen oder nicht und ich würde
gern noch eine frage anschließen wie ist
das mit ffp zwei masken die gibt es in
deutschland sehr selten die sind sehr
teuer die kriegt man in apotheken wenn
man das möchte
wäre das sinnvoll dass kinder ffp zwei
masken tragen und dass der staat auch
sowas zur verfügung stellt oder gibt es
dann eltern die sagen da kriegt man kind
überhaupt keine luft mehr das möchte ich
nicht
also das sind sehr wichtige und sehr
gute fragen sehr gute anmerkung auch
also zum ersten die schulen sollten
unbedingt offen bleiben denn wir halten
auch andere bereiche des öffentlichen
lebens offen und die kinder haben ein
recht auf die schule und die folgen die
durch die schulschließung entstanden
sind sind jetzt schon gravierend zu den
mann zu der masken frage es gibt ja zwei
möglichkeiten entweder die medizinischen
schutzmasken die sind in den meisten
fällen nicht nur ausreichend sie sind
insbesondere auch für kleine kinder
besser zu tragen denn die fdp drei
masken haben natürlich das problem dass
sie auch erwachsenen gesichter
zugeschnitten sind und eine nicht
adäquat sitzende nicht gut sitzende fb2
maske ist wesentlich schlechter als eine
gut sitzende medizinische schutzmaske
das was wir nicht nutzen sollten sind
die stoffmasken das sollte der
vergangenheit angehören
es ist vielleicht auch noch mal klar zu
sagen dass wir wissen dass die normalen
medizinischen schutzmasken überhaupt
keine einschränkung der arten fähigkeit
nach sich ziehen
die frp zwei masken sind bei anstrengung
und wenn man sie länger als 75 minuten
trägt unangenehm und können bei
vorbelasteten menschen auch zu dem
gefühl führen dass man schwerer luft
bekommt deswegen
unsere empfehlung sind bei kleinen
kindern ganz klar die medizinischen
schutzmasken erst bei großen kindern mit
ausgebildetem gesicht und kindern die
eben auch in der lage sind nach 75
minuten eine pause zu machen dann die
erhoffte zwei masken
sie haben gesagt sie sehen die kinder
nicht gefährdet in dieser pandemie
zumindest nicht durch das virus sondern
eher durch die kollateralschäden die
entstehen wenn man nicht in die schule
geht wenn man sich die zahlen der
letzten tage und wochen anguckt dann
könnte man wenn man sich damit
beschäftigt auch ein anderes gefühl
bekommen dass rk ii meldet zuletzt dass
sich bei der 0 bis 14 jährigen die
sieben tage incidents in den letzten
vier wochen verdoppelt hat mehr als
verdoppelt hat diese und andere zahlen
fast mein kollege jonas postfächer für
uns zusammen
die volkswagen nehmen rasant zu sind
alle altersgruppen getroffen
besonders stark allerdings die
berufstätigen bevölkerung das sind die
unter 65-jährigen und auch kinder und
jugendliche gesehen besonders viele
ansteckungen in privaten haushalten und
immer häufiger auch in kitas in schulen
und auch in arbeitsplätzen in das virus
verbreitet sich überall dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen
immer mehr infektionen in kitas und
schulen da verwandte rk ii präsident
lothar wieler bei den fünf- bis
neunjährigen liegt die inzidenz
inzwischen bei 126 bei den 15 bis 18
jährigen bei 139 einblick in die daten
zeigt in kitas und horten gibt es jetzt
deutlich mehr corona fälle als in der
zweiten welle im vergangenen herbst
sowohl bei den kindern als auch beim
personal haben sich die ansteckungen im
vergleich zu anfang januar mehr als
verdoppelt auch in den schulen steigen
die infektionszahlen merklich an
bislang bleiben die werte aber noch
unter denen der zweiten welle bis mitte
dezember waren die schulen aber im
regelbetrieb das sind sie aktuell nicht
an den schulen haben die infektionen von
sechs bis zehnjährigen kindern am
meisten zugenommen
das robert koch institut vermutet dass
die anstiege der infektionen mit der
britischen krone mutante die 117
zusammenhängen
diese ist leichter übertragbar als das
ursprüngliche virus für den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
ist deshalb klar dass an schulen
besonders viel getestet werden muss 17
geht durch die schulen wie das warme
messer durch die butter ist ganz
schrecklich und daher müssen wir in den
schulen testen
das muss absolute priorität haben denn
sonst gefährden wir kinder eltern und
lehrer herr professor dick machen ihnen
diese zahlen keine sorgen
natürlich machen uns macht uns die
aktuelle situation sorgen also die
britische variante die wesentlich
ansteckender es macht uns sorgen
studien aus großbritannien haben gezeigt
dass in allen altersgruppen
gleichermaßen das ist auch wichtig
gleichermaßen die ansteckung sich erhöht
das heißt also dass nicht etwa im kindes
und jugendalter die ansteckung größer
werden als bei erwachsenen
und das hat ja bieler ja in seinem durch
sehr korrekt abgebildeten statement auch
klar gesagt das betrifft nicht nur
kinder und jugendliche
ein zweiter punkt der ganz wichtig ist
wir haben wie sie richtig sagen eine
mehr als eine verdopplung in dieser
altersgruppe
allerdings haben wir auch gleichzeitig
eine art dreifach ung in dem gleichen
zeitraum eine verdreifachung der tests
wenn sie dreimal so viel testen ist es
nicht unwahrscheinlich dass sie auch
doppelt so viel positive bei
asymptomatischen trägern finden und die
letzte sache die auch noch wichtig ist
dass mehr kinder als infektiös
identifiziert werden oder als von der
infektion betroffen identifiziert werden
heißt noch nicht dass sie sich
gegenseitig angesteckt haben ganz im
gegenteil wir haben eine reihe von
studien die zeigen dass die ansteckung
unter kindern in schulen sehr gering ist
und gerade in der letzten woche ist im
deutschen ärzteblatt nochmal eine sehr
gute publikationen erschienen die
gezeigt hat dass sogenannten super
bretter die dann für große ausbrüche
verantwortlich sind dass die mit höherem
alter auftreten und mit höheren
körpergewicht so dass kinder die beides
weniger haben
ihr körpergewicht und auch weniger alter
natürlich deutlich weniger als rückpass
später haben in ihrer altersgruppe
weil sie die studien ansprechen wir
haben jetzt gelernt wir sind hier alle
zu möchtegern wissenschaftlern geworden
in dieser pandemie dass es viele studien
gibt und viele andere studien gibt und
jeder zieht dann die studie heran die er
gerade braucht für seine argumentation
heute in diesem eingangs erwähnten
spiegel artikel werden zum beispiel zwei
studien zitiert eine vom imperial
college aus london im januar aus der
hervorgeht dass das mutierte virus
bevorzugt kinder befällt sage ich jetzt
mal und es gibt auch eine untersuchung
an der britischen mathematikerin die das
belegt und es gibt einen belgischen
medizinprofessor von der freien
universität in brüssel
der sieht in brüssel die kinder und die
schulen als motor desinfektions
geschehens und schließt daraus dass auch
das ein grund dafür ist dass die zahl
der jüngeren patienten auf den
intensivstationen zunimmt und das
erleben wir in deutschland ja auch das
heißt da ist jetzt quasi nicht die
großeltern generation auf den
intensivstationen sondern zunehmend die
elterngeneration was macht sie denn so
sicher dass es nicht die kinder sind die
ihre eltern anstecken
die letzte frage ist natürlich richtig
also kinder können ihre eltern anstecken
und werden ihre kinder anstecken wenn
man dichten körperkontakt hast überhaupt
gar keine frage die frage ist woher
kommt die infektion der kinder und das
ist eben sozusagen noch die große frage
die nicht geklärt ist und die er auch in
den zum teil auch in dem spiegel artikel
noch nicht publizierten studien also die
sind leider auch noch nicht zugänglich
der wissenschaftlichen öffentlichkeit
und können denn so kann auch nicht
geprüft werden
das so dass man auch nicht ganz genau
weiß was ist da genau an fragestellungen
an methodik untersucht ich halte das
deswegen für aber ich finde was sie
sagen ist völlig richtig
wir haben manchmal evidenz in eine
richtung manchmal wie dance in eine
andere richtung das hängt immer sehr
stark von der wissenschaftlichen methode
ab das hängt auch sehr stark davon ab
natürlich in welcher welle der pandemie
die daten erhoben
wurden und wie gut sie bereits von
anderen wissenschaftlern geprüft werden
konnten also die daten aus der ersten
welle der pandemie sind natürlich sehr
viel sicherer als aus der zweiten und
der dritten da noch nicht genügend zeit
bestand sie im wissenschaftlichen
kontext und in der wissenschaftlichen
community gut zu prüfen
deswegen ist das was wir besonders
brauchen nämlich eigentlich möglichst
schnelle aussagen auch besonders
anfällig gegenüber fehlern und das ist
die sorge die ich habe im hinblick auf
diese sehr kurzfristigen sehr schnell
geäußerten aussagen die wir jetzt im
moment hören und das bringt uns wieder
zurück zu dem was sie wie ich finde es
sehr sehr richtig auch in dem beitrag
jetzt dargestellt habe und auch die
kollegin aus der virologie sehr gut und
sehr klug dargestellt hat es geht nicht
jetzt darum unbedingt recht zu haben
unbedingt darum zu beweisen dass man von
anfang an richtig lag als man gedacht
hat dass die kinder sich gegenseitig
anstecken es geht darum sicherheit zu
schaffen sicherheit für die lehrkräfte
sicherheit für die eltern sicherheit
auch für die kinder und das habe ich
schon gesagt die sicherheit für die
kinder besteht darin dass sie ihren
normalen schulischen alltag nachgehen
können und in der lage sind nicht in
defizite und den sozialen presse
gesteckt zu hätten geschickt zu werden
das heißt wir müssen hier
zielgruppengerecht auch arbeiten das ist
eine ganz wichtige forderung von seiten
der deutschen gesellschaft für kinder
und jugendmedizin weil sie die studien
angesprochen haben es gibt wenig wenige
deutsche studien und jetzt natürlich zu
dieser mutation nicht nur in deutschland
so gut wie keine sondern auch in anderen
ländern so gut wie keine denn sie ist
nun mal erst vor wenigen wochen und
monaten aufgetreten
aber es gibt eine studie eines ihrer
kollegen professor doktor jacob ammann
kinderarzt am uniklinikum dresden der
untersucht seit dem sommer 2020 wie sich
das corona virus in den kitas
ausgebreitet hat und auch mit ihm
konnten wir im vorfeld dieser sendung
sprechen
mit diesen dramatischen anstieg der
fallzahlen dann insbesondere auch in
sachsen in der zweiten welle haben wir
nun ungefähr eine richtungs rate bei
eltern und erziehern von zehn prozent
erreicht also zehn prozent der eltern da
sie bei uns teilnehmen sind
infiziert gewesen mit dem neuen corona
virus bei den kindern hatten wir so
etwas 6 prozent der kinder der
teilnehmenden kinder mit einer infektion
also niedriger als bei den eltern und
erziehern
was auch sehr interessant ist dass wenn
wir uns angucken
bei den erziehern sind die erzieher die
mit den kindern kontakt haben oder die
eher bürotätigkeiten durchführen stärker
betroffen
fällt auf dass deutlich mehr erzieher
die bürotätigkeiten durchführen
durch sind als die die ich mit den
kindern arbeiten das lässt eben darauf
schließen dass die übertragung hier im
bereich der büros der gemeinschaftsräume
unter den erwachsenen stattfinden als
das wichtig kinder der auslöser dieser
ketten sich der professor
ich schließe mal eine frage von willi
über youtube an der nochmal fragt sind
denn die erwachsenen gefährdet durch die
kinder sie haben vorhin gesagt ja auch
die kinder stecken ihre eltern an aber
wenn man sich die ergebnisse dieser
studie die wie gesagt noch nicht die
mutation miteinbezogen hat aber vor
allem in den letzten monaten
festgestellt hat dass sich in den kitas
die erzieher angesteckt haben die
untereinander kontakt hatten aber
weniger mit den kindern dann müsste man
die frage von willi mit nein beantworten
oder ich dass das so ganz einfach ist es
glaube ich nicht also es ist natürlich
so und ich muss sagen herr namens
stimmig absolut zu 100 prozent zu wir
wissen nach wie vor auch bei der
britischen variante gibt es ja hat jetzt
deutliche anzeichen dafür dass die
erwachsenen sich leichter anstecken
es gibt eine ähnliche studie wie die von
der name hand gerade geschilderte aus
den schulen die zeigt dass die
ansteckung die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ich zwei lehrer anstecken
um den faktor vier jetzt auch mit der
britischen variante höher ist als die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sozusagen die
transmission von dem kind auch an lehrer
erfolgt aber das sozusagen jetzt nur
noch mal prinzipiell es ist einfach so
dass man dass es auch unehrlich wäre zu
sagen ein kind kann einen erwachsenen
nicht anstecken
und das hängt von der intensität des
körperkontakte sub das ist überhaupt gar
keine frage nur man muss die frage
stellen woher kommt die infektion der
kinder kommt sie jetzt
ich jetzt von anderen kindern und das
ist nach wie vor relativ
unwahrscheinlich oder kommt sie von
erwachsenen sprich den eltern
sprich vielleicht auch besuchern der
eltern kontaktpersonen oder eben auch
professionellen personal mit dem die
kinder in kontakt sind
das ist der wir sehr viel
wahrscheinlichere weg und dass die
kinder dann wenn sie auf dem schoß der
eltern sitzen und darf vielleicht auch
eine halbe stunde kuscheln eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit haben die eltern mit
dem virus in kontakt zu bringen
das liegt einfach in der natur der sache
aber das wiederum bringt natürlich die
kitas und die schulen doch wieder in den
fokus weil das nun mal im moment so
ziemlich die einzigen orte sind außer
den arbeitsstätten wo viele leute sehr
engen kontakt haben
news pp fragt über youtube finden sie
also wie professor durch den aktuellen
kurs der kultusministerkonferenz gut und
warum darf ich mich auf arbeit mit 40
kindern ohne abstand und maske treffen
also offenbar ein erzieher der das hier
schreibt während mir ein treffen mit
mehr als einer person im privaten
verwehrt bleibt ja also ich glaube die
frage kann man gut beantworten es ist
der private kontakt ist in der regel
näher und intensiver das ist das was ich
eben auch sagt um da letztlich auch die
auch bei der wahrheit zu bleiben und es
ist so dass der schulische kontakt
natürlich nicht einfach es mit 40
kindern und jugendlichen das halte ich
auch für eine sehr große zahl und
deswegen haben wir auch empfohlen im
rahmen einer leitlinie einer breit
angelegten je nachdem wie die inzidenz
zahlen sind dass man eben auch dann auf
entsprechende dotierung zurückgreift
beziehungsweise wechsel unterricht
zugreift das ist ja alles empfohlen und
auch konzentriert also 40 kinder in
einem engen raum ohne
lüftungsmöglichkeiten das halten das
hält niemand von uns im moment für eine
sinnvolle lösung
deswegen ist das und das entspricht auch
nicht dem was die
kultusministerkonferenz möchte die
kultusministerkonferenz möchte ganz
eindeutig dass die schulen offen
gehalten werden
aber dass die schule neben unter
möglichst hohen sicherheitsbedingungen
offen
werden und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich muss meinen hohen respekt auch vor
den schulen ministerin und
kultusministerin zum ausdruck bringen
ich halte das für den absolut richtigen
weg sich damit auseinanderzusetzen wie
machen wir die schulen sicherer und
nicht zu dem reflex zugreifen die
schulen zu schließen
dann lassen sie uns mal darauf blicken
wie gefährlich das virus für kinder ist
sie haben eingangs gesagt sie sehen
keine erhöhten kranken kinder zahlen auf
den stationen in den kliniken wenn
kinder im moment erkranken wie schwer
erkranken sie und wie äußert sich das im
moment ja also in der regel erkranken
die kinder zum glück durch des corona
virus selbst sehr leicht
wir haben selten sehr sehr selten und in
den letzten monaten seit die britische
variante unterwegs ist ja noch seltener
kinder stationär
was damit zusammenhängen mag das ein
teil der kinder gerade der anfangs
positions- gekommen sind weil die eltern
selbst erkrankt waren und es den eltern
zu schlecht ging um direkt nach
versorgen zu können
also da waren es auch die gründe die
elterlichen gründe die zur aufnahme der
kinder geführt haben
es gibt eine zweite gruppe von kindern
die etwas häufiger in die kliniken
kommen das sind diejenigen die ein
zweites kranksein erleben nach der kogit
infektion
und das liegt daran dass das immunsystem
manchmal sehr stark reagiert auf die
viren und diese sehr starke
immunreaktion dann später zu ähnlichen
krankheitssymptomen führt wie es die
starke inflation machen kann
die kinder haben dann fieber die haben
manchmal lymphknotenschwellungen haben
einen hautausschlag
zum großen glück kennen wir das schon
aus anderen von anderen erkrankungen und
haben auch gute behandlungsmöglichkeiten
hier für das was sie ansprechen ist tims
also eine entzündungserkrankungen in
verschiedenen organen nämlich an oder
meinen sie was anderes denn wenn es bei
uns wäre und dann noch hörte es sich mir
jetzt an von der beschreibung was sie
genannt haben
dann hören wir noch mal herrn professor
ammann der nämlich dass kims register
verwaltet und da auch noch ein bisschen
auskunft geben kann wie die zahlen denn
aktuell sind wir haben inzwischen wir
haben im mai 2020 begonnen diese fälle
zu sammeln und haben jetzt gut 250 fälle
in diesem zeitraum also fast einem jahr
gesammelt das ist wenn man dann sieht
dass wir ungefähr 13 14 millionen kinder
und jugendliche haben ist es jetzt keine
besonders hohe zahl in relation und auch
wenn man die meldezahlen also stand
letzte woche sind etwas über 350.000
kinder mit fas cause 2 infiziert
gemeldet bei mercury ist es auch ein
kleiner anteil davon
diese kinder die das teams entwickeln
sind schwer krank sind in aller regel
aber gut behandelbar und auch nur ein
kleiner teil hat folge stellen davon
herr professor wenn man sieht dass kims
verzögert kommt also ein paar wochen
nach der infektion und wir sehen jetzt
dass die zahlen steigen muss man dann
damit rechnen dass auch die ps zahlen in
den nächsten wochen steigen werden
ja wie gesagt wir wissen noch gar nicht
wie stark die zahlen jetzt wirklich
gestiegen sind
ich hatte es vorhin gesagt wir haben
eine wir haben mehr als eine verdopplung
der zahlen aber wir haben eine
vertreibung wird dreifach und tests und
haben damit viele asymptomatische kinder
entdeckt also ich bin mir noch nicht
ganz sicher wie viele kinder wirklich
mehr erkrankt sind im moment soweit ja
auch in der vergangenheit beobachtet
wurde bei kindern die automatica
symptomatische verläufe hatten also
steht und deshalb kriegt dass er
unabhängig von den tests also die
positiven fälle bei kindern die sind ja
da wo woran das jetzt auch immer liegt
also es gibt diese bestimmte absolute
zahl von positiv getesteten kindern die
korona haben im moment ob symptomatisch
oder asymptomatisch und ob die jetzt
teams entwickeln das lässt sich im
moment einfach noch nicht sagen aber die
gefahr ist ja vorhanden oder die die
gefahr ist vorhanden und gleichzeitig
die songs richtig die haben doch vorher
nicht getestet die kinder und mussten
sich testen weil symptomatisch das hat
ihm hätten sie besser gefunden aber wir
haben sie nicht getestet weil sie als
symptomatisch waren und wer nicht aus
anderer integration getestet haben jetzt
testen wir sie jetzt finden wir mehr als
symptomatische kinder
aber das heißt nicht dass wir wirklich
mehr kinder haben die im moment kopiert
haben
selbst wenn es so wäre damit hat es
wunderbar zusammengefasst 250 kinder
letztlich in einem ganzen jahr in
deutschland das ist letztlich das was
wir auch sehen bei dieser situation
vorher wird das ist ja eine
vergleichbare situation zu den
sogenannten kawasaki syndrom das eine
etwas stärkere form wenn man so möchte
noch films ist und das ist auch durch
alle anderen möglichen anderen erreger
ausgelöst werden konnte durch mikro
plasmen viren bakterien also wir kennen
diese erkrankung sie war schon immer ein
teil unserer wirklichkeit und im moment
sind andere erkrankungs erreger auch
zurückgegangen und insofern wird das
traditionelle kawasaki-syndrom im moment
seltener gesehen dafür als teams etwas
in den vordergrund gerückt ich bin noch
nicht sicher dass wir wirklich eine
deutliche vermehrung von kindern eclipse
sehen werden
im moment sieht es noch nicht danach aus
denn das primus fängt oft so fünf bis
acht tage nach der infektion an
und jetzt haben wir ja doch schon seit
einigen wochen die scheinbar erhöhte
fallzahl bei kindern und jugendlichen
insofern müssten das mittlerweile schon
sehen dass du noch war noch nicht ich
würde gerne zum abschluss noch mit ihnen
kurz über das impfen sprechen wie
wichtig wie hoffnungsfroh sehen sie
einem impfstoff für kinder entgegen bei
und tech prüft jetzt gerade einen
impfstoff bei unter zwölfjährigen bei
moderner laufen gerade studien an einem
impfstoff für kinder aber die sind noch
nicht in reichweite wie wichtig wäre
dass impfen bei kindern ja also wir
halten das impfen bei kindern aus zwei
gründen sehr wichtig der erste grund ist
der dass natürlich kinder letztlich und
wenn es auch nur die wenigen sind die
erholsamen zum ausdruck gebracht hat da
hatten es für wichtig um zu verhindern
dass die kinder dieses pimps das zweite
kranksein bekommen wir halten es aber
auch der anderen seite auch für wichtig
dass die kinder im rahmen
dessen was ihnen nicht schadet hier
einen beitrag auch zur
gesamtgesellschaftlichen eindämmung der
pandemie leisten und ein dritter grund
der natürlich auch nicht unerheblich ist
ist wenn kinder geschützt sind vor der
infektion
dann besteht natürlich auch nicht die
gefahr dass sie in quarantäne müssen und
dann erneut schule verpassen
also insofern sind wir auf jeden fall
für die impfung aber wir sind erst dann
für die impfung wenn die impfstoffe wie
sie richtig gesagt haben ausreichend
geprüft sind bei kindern und
jugendlichen
und zum glück hat die ema die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde seit
einigen jahren die verpflichtung
ausgesprochen dass alle neuen
medikamente und impfstoffe an kindern
auch geprüft werden müssen
die fristen sind relativ lang bis das
erfolgt sein muss aber wir hoffen doch
sehr dass wir zum ende des jahres dann
doch gestoppt die kinder zur verfügung
haben und dann müsste ja eigentlich auch
dann die durchimpfung der erwachsenen
bevölkerung so weit fortgeschritten sein
dass wir die impfstoffe für die kinder
auch haben um sie zu schützen
wir erleben letzte frage herr professor
dick weil ich auch merkel ihre leitungen
möchte ins wochenende
wir erleben gerade eine große im skepsis
bei erwachsenen glauben sie dass das
wenn es dann um das impfen der kinder
geht noch mal neu hoch kochen wird
ich hoffe nicht also ich hoffe sehr dass
die die verunsicherung die jetzt
entstanden ist die auch vielleicht
deswegen entstanden ist weil das so
schwer zu begreifen ist das wenn eine
impfung so viele menschen leben doch
retten kann dass man dann eine pause
einlegen muss um sicher zu sein dass
eine maßnahme nicht mehr schadet als sie
als sie nutzt das diese verunsicherung
die dabei vielen menschen dadurch
entstanden ist
doch bald durch die wirklichen fakten
und die positiven auswirkungen der
impfung die wir jetzt schon sehen bei
den über 80-jährigen sich in eine
deutlichere befürwortung der info
wandeln wird
ich bin da ich bin da optimistisch weil
ich der meinung bin dass weder die
nebenwirkung langwierig so gravierend
sein werden wie das wie das scheinbar
schienen und und wie gesagt gleichzeitig
wir merken jetzt schon die effekte wir
merken dass es weniger todesfälle gibt
wir merken es sind weniger über
80-jährige auf den intensivstationen und
ich glaube dieser diese zuversicht ich
dadurch entsteht die wird sich auch auf
die im billigkeit von uns allen dann so
bald wie möglich jungen schauen sagt der
kinder- und jugendmediziner professor
jörg butt vielen herzlichen dank dass
sie bei uns im stream zu gast waren
dankeschön für ihre daten und
einschätzungen und ich bedanke mich auch
ganz herzlich bei ihnen und euch zuhause
für eure fragen und kommentare und sagen
tschüss und ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]